we know you like watching key and Peele
on YouTube but you love watching the
whole show even more on Comedy Central
one at a time
hardwood men like you behind bars every
day one at odd you may take my heels but
cannot lock my soul away
oh the years ahead in the shadows on the
shame
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
now this is just the Joker second he was
taking
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's the city on fire what's with all
the smoke oh now we're all ears right
[Laughter]
you know what thanks so much for
watching that sketch that you just saw
online from key & peele season 3 you can
see more sketches from key & peele that
aren't online on our actual television
show it'll be great yes 10:30
Wednesday's on Comedy Central and now
please check out this sneak peek of next
week's episode mm-hmm why everybody
messing with the Batman I mean when
Danny DeVito's tried walking around the
Strongs now you still haven't explained
to me why we found the words target
Washington 49 times I was in DC for a
dog show and I had to buy a squeezy toy
a birthday card and some deodorant all
at an affordable price can only do
yeah
[Music]